all right hi everybody welcome to the
last session of day two of NDC make sure
you're in the right place I like that
enthusiasm I always hate being the one
before the attendee party because
everyone's probably downstairs just
warming themselves up before all the
festivities this is my first time in
London my first time in the UK my first
in DC I'm very excited to be here those
who have never seen me before my name's
Kevin I'm from the great land of the
United States of America is specifically
the Norfolk Virginia area so a little
fact if you're not familiar with the
United States that's fine
Virginia is home to Norfolk which is the
world's largest naval base so that's the
little thing about the area that I live
in other things I'm a Microsoft MVP my
focus has always been in asp.net
building web applications and the points
up to Microsoft Azure independent
consultant in trainer so if you ever
want to talk about stuff afterwards
please feel free to reach out to me I
would love to talk to you I'm always on
Twitter and you can always email me now
I'll put this up at the end if you want
to but today we're going to talk about
building client applications for the web
specifically with an asp.net back-end or
asp.net core back end so kind of Reason
hands who's been developing web
applications with asp.net since the
early webform days all right that's a
good number of folks whose development
Razer all right awesome who's developed
but just raw HTML and JavaScript and
they talk to a dotnet back-end all right
not as many hands so we've seen this
progression of how we as dotnet
developers build web applications on top
of asp.net and we really I probably more
time I do a whole history lesson but I
love web form so I started as a web
forms developer quickly moved to NBC
when that became a thing in the 1.0 days
but I love web forms because
waveforms had one single fundamental job
and that was to convert winform
developers to web developers so have you
developed anything with ASP net web
forms 1.1 you know exactly what I'm
talking about you were just being
converted to a different type of
developer and all the tools were there
everything was click drag and drop you
could see what you're rendering and the
code underneath looked awful like we
were not developing in JavaScript we are
developing everything in dotnet c-sharp
VB if you were unlucky and you were
spitting out HTML that looked horrendous
we made tons of mistakes and we were
looking for a better way to do things
especially with JavaScript libraries and
frameworks becoming more prevalent move
the MVC we got our hands on razor and
razor was a little bit more of a
systematic approach to writing HTML but
still sprinkling in the bits of c-sharp
that we really liked so you would get a
rendered output that was pure HTML and
you could relate that directly back to
where you wrote the code in a razor page
but then we have this new idea of just
raw HTML Javascript and just having AP
eyes as our back ends that we can send
data to or get data from and that's what
we're going to really concentrate on
today I have done this talk three
different times and each of those three
times I hated it it was a horrible
horrible presentation so I took all the
lessons I learned from giving this
presentation before I rewrote the entire
app and the entire presentation so
you're getting v2 of this presentation
which I feel is much better it's got
probably 40 more slides it's more
discussion questions I have asked along
the way figuring out how to build single
page applications with dotnet backends
but the terms view
UJS you can really substitute that for
angular for react I have built major
production applications in all three of
these technologies are all 50 of these
technology if you count every version of
angular but if I had to really pick what
I like
I'd go with view every single time and
that's not because it's the latest
greatest thing that everyone's trying to
use is that I fundamentally believe it
is a better technology than the other to
put together I don't say that lightly
all these technologies are great they do
their job but I would rank it view then
react and then angularjs which was
amazing and then they got rid of it and
wrote angular 2 and one thing you'll
learn about me I'm opinionated I have a
ton of opinions and I'll gladly talk
about them over a pipe but we have these
new ways of developing web applications
and doesn't matter which of these
technologies you're using they all kind
of have the same fundamentals number one
they're all CLI base so command line
interfaces if you want true success with
any of these client-side technologies
you're using a CLI because angular in
particular is horrible if you try to go
off the script react works slightly
better if you try to go off the script
View will work perfectly for just simple
applications but if you're building a
spa a single page application you want
to use the view CLI they just give you
all the tools they do all the work for
you our whole development and deployment
process happens outside of our back-end
so if I'm building an API that serves up
data or handles things like talking to a
database that development is completely
separate so I have two applications that
I'm technically managing which is
slightly different from the way that we
did things with web forms or with razor
pages because you're used to everything
being in the same solution one instance
of visual studio and everything was in
one place
now I have one editor that's just my
front end and I have another editor
that's all my back end our friend lien
doesn't care where it gets data from so
if I'm loading up a view that's a list
of users
well view angular react doesn't care
where that data is coming from it can go
to a an asp.net core back-end it can go
to a server this function lambda or or
as your functions it doesn't matter
oh I switched up my thing
it doesn't so the friendly doesn't care
where it's served from what I mean by
that is it doesn't have to be served up
by an asp.net application it doesn't
need to be served up by we can just put
in blob storage up in Azure or we can
put in an s3 container we can put our
front in anywhere because it's just HTML
Javascript and CSS so I asked myself
this question a couple years ago making
the movie asp.net core what was the most
efficient way to build a web application
that would utilize the best parts of
asp.net core but also the best parts of
whatever client library I was using and
eventually coming to wjs so I this way I
have made a ton of mistakes in all three
technologies I've landed on the best
possible solution that I can think of
and that is view Jas with a dotnet core
back-end and what we'll do is we'll talk
about my progression of what questions I
asked to get to the solution and just
giving you the answer so you don't have
to do this research yourself all right a
couple quick goals of this talk
talk about my approach tell you the
questions I've asked myself and give you
the answers I'm going to talk about a
lot of tools use this for something use
that for something else I want to tell
you why I'm telling you to use these
particular tools not just telling you go
use view X because that's good for state
management I want to explain why that's
something you need to know
you will not learn everything you need
to know about UJS or asp net core if you
don't are any no view you'll still get
something out of this talk I'll show you
enough you where you'll be comfortable
with the concepts but it's not like at
the end of this talk
you're gonna go write a full scale view
application we still have to do a little
bit of that work yourself alright so
let's talk about the architecture of a
single page application it's not a new
concept it's been around for several
years actually wrote a single page app a
long long time ago in 2007 using asp.net
webforms
and using an update our update panel
it's a blast to the past for anyone and
it works horribly it worked really well
at the time in 2007 I sat back and went
I am a genius
this works amazingly and now in 2020 I
go that was some awful code
I should have been fired on the spot I
don't know why we deployed that but the
architecture of a single page
application looks something like this
again it's two applications on the left
side our ASP 8 on the core app is going
to be our back-end and this has three
main responsibilities can have more it
could have less number one is just data
access if I'm talking to a database
sequel server Postgres cosmos you name
it I'm going to go through this back-end
to to get access to that data then my
core application is also responsible for
authentication and authorization we'll
talk more about this in a couple minutes
but if I'm going to access any of his
data I want to make sure I'm going
through the correct firewalls
do I have permission to do the actions
that I want to do on the right side I
have my front-end my UJS out and this is
responsible for just showing things to
the user this is my UI and a couple big
things it will be responsible for
routing or more importantly what should
I show the user based off what's in the
the address bar
state management so if I'm running a
single page app I'm not constantly going
back to the server to load new HTML like
in a razor page I'm not going back to
the server to load new HTML every single
time I'll have all the HTML I need I
just need to know which HTML to show and
then go to the server to get data and
load that data into the page and then my
PJs app will have to figure out how does
it go talk back to the espionage asp.net
core app to get data or to post new data
I call that data fetching or Ajax from
the olden days
alright so question number one before we
get started what do you need to know
about view assuming you have no view
experience number one view is a
client-side app for building web
application frameworks shows like
angular is just like react heck it so
it's just like jQuery and it they all do
fundamentally the same thing just a
little bit differently based on
components and not web components which
is a buzzword right now because that's
the way the web will eventually want to
go but this is a component or an idea of
component and as three fundamental parts
the template the HTML that we're going
to render on the page any Styles
associated with that HTML on the page
and the JavaScript the code that makes
that template work it's almost like a
racer page or more like a web form so a
web form you have your your front-end
and you have your code behind and this
is makes up one single fundamental
component what's unique about something
like this it's all self-contained when
this gets deployed this is the HTML for
the component the code for the component
and you can even scope the styles to
that particular component so you don't
have any issues with maybe CSS conflict
with something else on the page so then
this one component can get reused
wherever you need it to it's shipped as
one single thing all right and view is
limited opinion well touch on this a
little bit more in a moment but you is
going to do as little or as much as you
wanted to do so when I say limited
opinion in this example this view
component does nothing it's just
rendering some HTML on the page but I
could set this up to do two-way binding
between data inside my my code and
elements in my template it will do that
SEP for me but it won't do things like
Ajax requests for you but we'll come
back to that how do you set up a view
app this goes back to our CLI
conversation a moment ago and then even
read the reason I put it in the slide
deck is because you have to make some
big decisions setting up your app
initially that if you don't do it it's a
little bit of a headache to go back and
fix it so first you installed the CLI
it's JavaScript so you have NPM or you
have yarn anyone use yarn one one guy
okay well that's about what I say most
people use NPM because we always have it
installed install the CLI and then you
can use the view command Oh
why would we use the CLI a couple of big
things you don't have to use the CLI for
view specifically you can use it sort of
the same way we would use jquery drop it
on the page write a little bit of code
everything works but when we start
running single page applications there's
a lot more to an app than just writing a
little bit of JavaScript so I'll show
you example when we're all done a big
full sample app but you don't want to
write a single page app framework by
hand you rather that be done for you
that's what the CLI does the scaffolding
is the nice part having not the scaffold
out all these different bits and pieces
helps a ton but the big thing is really
with upgrades and there's hot reload hot
reload is like way down the list of
benefits so if you update the code wait
a second your page will refresh because
the development server is linked to your
browser and those whenever you update a
component maybe you changed some HTML
you change some JavaScript it updates
the page this is the big one this is why
it would tell anyone to use this UI is
because this is open source it's
continuously being upgraded
so not just point releases but every now
and then a major release and I have
learned this lesson the hard way
specifically with react I created a
react app and said to myself all right
CLI is good but I'm better than the CLI
so I'm going to what they call eject the
app from the react CLI so what it does
is just gives you all all the
configuration all the code and you can
go in and you can maintain that stuff
yourself because I said I am smarter
than the tool you're never smarter than
the tool because what happened reacts
got a major upgrade I said okay well
this should be easy
go into my NPM stuff and I'll just
change the versions and everything will
be great up to fix a little bit code
know the upgrade required an upgrade of
webpack now if you never heard a web
pack it's this really cool tool that
compiles and makes all your code really
small and tidy but its configuration is
a pain in the butt who's ever worked
with web pack directly all right one to
two hands so I would hope you agree with
me web pack is awful to configure by
hands so I had to basically go from web
pack but three to four or two to three I
don't remember which it was but I
couldn't do it physically couldn't do it
because
the dependencies of webpack and every
little change I had to make kept making
the application worse it just wouldn't
work at all so we hit this point where
we physically cannot upgrade the
application because we couldn't figure
out how and it wasn't worth our time
trying to figure it out eventually we
brought the entire application back into
the react CLI framework just so we could
do upgrades but that was it was ten
seconds of effort to take it out it was
ten hours of effort to put it back in so
no ever eject from your CLI leave it in
the CLI until the end of time all right
but when you use the CLI you'll save you
create and you'll give your application
a fancy name make sure it's all
lowercase or else it will yell at you
and there are some presets that you'll
get by default and never use the presets
when creating a new application just
because it's so much fun to go through
the wizard so let's assume we select
manually select features instead it's
gonna ask you a bunch of things that you
might want to put into your CLI use
babel by default
babbles useful if you're supporting
older browsers anyone apps support
Internet Explorer 11 really holy crap
if I was in the States every hand would
be up right now let me move here
typescript to anyone using typescript a
couple hands all right so if you prefer
typescript it can scaffold the entire
thing in typescript if you're supporting
one a PWA
for any operating system that supports
it you can get that built in
automatically but for our cases you'll
probably want the router for actually
making a single page app you want view X
for state management which will talk
about CSS preprocessors you probably
don't necessarily need you can always
add them in later if you need them
you'll want the linter or the 4matic
this is really useful just for
double-checking your your JavaScript or
your typescript making sure you're
writing it correctly and you don't need
unit testing
that's a fad I'm glad you're all
chuckling it's sometimes I do that and I
just offend people I
what type of lint you want it doesn't
matter I just like err prevention only
lint unsaved yeah this is all just silly
things oh this is a big one
put all your configuration into
dedicated files for I don't even know
why they asked this this should be
default no matter what but you could put
configuration into your package.json
file but then it's it's harder to
configure I like data dedicated config
files just because you'll find yourself
wanting to make adjustments to es lint
or view in particular it's just easier
this way it does a whole bunch of magic
I usually do this demo live and realize
depending on internet it can take five
minutes so I skip that part and when
you're all done you get fancy fancy new
directory all right now I have to run it
you go and you say NPM serve and this
generates what we call the development
build of the application and run the
development server so you can go to
localhost whatever the port is and it'll
show you the current application running
you could then run lo the application up
in say BS code or whatever your editor
is of choice and make adjustments every
time you hit save on a file it will
recompile and automatically update the
page that you're currently looking at
and there's also some tools for
specifically editing UJS if we have time
I'll show those but rest assure you get
source mapping so any code that you
write it's going to get compiled so the
compiled output is ugly hard to read but
with source mapping you can edit it just
like it's inside your editor this is
what the default app looks like nothing
special but if you get this far you just
you know you didn't screw anything up
you have a good base do get commit and
start start changing things the SPM
we built our front end now we want to
build our back in this is much easier
two ways you could do this way number
one you use the command line down a new
web
I prefer empty projects because I love
having clean slate stuff that I can
build on top of there's a plethora of
other asp.net templates you can use but
this will do all your work for you the
other way is you can go in the visual
studio for you if you prefer visual
studio and do file new the important
thing is when you're done you have two
distinct directories because there are
two distinct applications your front-end
is your view app and your back-end is
your ASP nightcore app you could try to
put the front-end code somewhere inside
of the back end that's the way we used
to do it with web forms or razor pages I
don't recommend that this is the
approach I think is work best for us so
has this ball work with we we built our
our scaffold both our front end our back
end so how exactly does a spa work with
UJS when you start working with UJS you
are essentially serving up one HTML file
index.html and this is what it looks
like out of the gate you can edit this
to put in whatever you want to if you
want to add meta tags you want to change
the title if you want to have a funny
picture when they don't have JavaScript
enabled you can do that the two
important things you need well really
the one important thing you need is this
line 18 that you have a div this one's
called app and that's the div that UJS
is going to put everything inside of so
anything inside app will be controlled
by bjs and then you have this line here
at the end and it doesn't necessarily
have to be line 19 you can put stuff
before it but it's really the line
before the end the body end tag
what you will do when you rather the
development server or you run a
production build is any file that gets
generated or files the script includes
will get injected right here can't
change that it's just they're always
going to be there if you need to add
other script tags maybe I use stripe for
credit card processing well I have to
include a script tag for that I just I
put it up here I can also put it down
here in the bottom if I want to view J s
is going to reserve the line before the
end body tag for any includes that it
wants to do so this is HTML gets served
over to the browser router render its
renders it it takes over the app div and
we create inside of that what we call a
slot and a slot is going to be whatever
the current component is supposed to be
loaned to memory and this is done with a
route so you see my example here my
domain slash route a well view we'll
know that whenever route a is in the
address bar it should load a certain
view well if I click on a link or I
navigate to another route alright maybe
I type another route up in the address
bar view takes that as a sign as I need
to replace whatever is currently inside
of that slot and we can get unique with
it so the slot doesn't necessarily need
to be the entire app I could have a
header and navigation bar outside of the
slot that's always the same and I just
want to change the the content inside of
it
I could have sidebars I can't footers
all the exits up can be a frame around
this slot so how do you tell view what
components you use depending on the
route well this is where the view router
comes into effect and you'll get it by
default if you use the CLI and tell it
you want the router if you forget to
tell the view CLI that you want the
router you can always install it
afterward
with a UJS plugin and it will create all
the scaffold code for you still but this
is all it looks like you tell view you
want to use the view router and then you
define as series or routes so lines 9 10
11 is one route 14 15 16 is another
route and we're just telling view that
when you see the naked routes are just a
slash I want to go to a component called
home and I want to call it home so the
two major things here you want to give
all your routes a name because then you
can reference them by name later in the
application this is useful what if your
routes change in the future because
sometimes they do well if you're
referencing everything by name the route
path can change but you don't have to
find and replace throughout your code to
figure out what what needs to be updated
so I'm about slash about will load the
about component and it doesn't in a very
special way but I'll talk about that in
just a sec so the thing to know here
when this gets compiled by the the
development server or in production
build view is going to go through look
for everything that you're importing
every component you want to use this is
easy this is one two components our apps
have 50-plus components different
possible views that we can go to so it's
compiling all these into JavaScript
files that will get delivered down to
the browser at runtime so when this when
this page gets loaded every view I have
will get loaded at that moment if you
have 50 of them that might take up a few
seconds so what do you do if all right
so yes it loads all commodes went page
renders but you can use lazy loading and
this is this is a really good tip as
you're designing your app
if there are some views that you don't
want to have loaded when the page
renders for the first time you can lazy
load them and this is the syntax you
have to use instead of just importing
your component before the routes get
defined you you setup a lambda that says
well when we need the about component go
import it from some web packed chunk you
don't need to say web pack chunk name
the reason we would do this is because
then I can look in my network stack and
see all the different files because the
file name that gets downloaded when we
need this view will say something
something about and it's easy to
identify so do this on pages that you
are pretty sure people won't need every
single time these will get loaded on
demand alright let's talk a little bit
more about a view component there are
several ways to build view components
I'm only going to show you one because
it's the most useful way to write single
page applications the term we use is
single file components so if you go
Google or Bing or whatever you use view
single file components this is what it's
going to show you you've already seen
this screenshot you have your separate
template your separate styles and your
scripts so this makes up one single
component we don't need go much more
into that what does the development
process look like
so we have our scaffold we know how to
use our command line what does our
process of pulling in our single page
application and our data core app is 2
min we are doing some sort of day access
way our browser we have some network
this might be local we have our asp.net
core app running on one port and we have
our view j/s app running on another port
that means if I'm running this locally
my view j/s app
for any Ajax request it makes has to go
to the network to my asp.net core app so
I have to tell it everywhere here is the
URL for the application that I'm running
now this is just my personal opinion I
don't like this approach because I have
two URLs that I'm managing whereas I am
used to in a web forms or a razor world
everything's coming from the same URL
even Ajax requests I can just say well
go go get the data a slash API slash
something what else do I need to worry
about with two separate URLs policies
that's right cross domain so if I'm
developing an app or cross domain or
cross origin policies I now have to set
one up for localhost because it's a
different port it's a different origin
so my view jas app will fail if it tries
to make the requests immediately unless
I tell the asp.net core let everything
in or you can let localhost 8080 one in
I don't like that approach because
that's not how it is in in production
and production my HTML is going to get
served up from the same URL my API calls
are going to get served up from the same
URL so I want I want to mimic dev I want
dev to mimic prod as much as possible
what I wanted to do is look like this
why have my browser that talks to my ASP
ionic core app but for any non API call
I wanted to serve up the compiled UJS
app all right so how do we do that in
depth alright
browser network we have our ASP at my
core app still running on a different
port we still have our Vijay s app
running on a different port but we
create between them a proxy and there
are two ways you can do this you can
have the asp.net core app proxy to wjs
app or you have the VJ s app proxy to
asp.net core
this approach is the easiest in my
opinion going from asp net core to VJ s
you can do the other way but this is
easier for me so what this means is I
open the browser I type in localhost
14500 whatever your port is and let's
say I just want to slash just give me
index well it's going to go to a
Hispanic or out asp.net course gonna say
I can't do anything with this well
instead of returning a 4 or 4 it's going
to proxy or send it off to our view j/s
server running on a different port now
it's mujhey s's responsibility to return
something it will always always return
either index.html or the corresponding
javascript CSS files but this means no
matter what I'm doing I'm using the same
URL every single time setting this up is
trivial but not documented like all good
Microsoft features you have to learn
about this through a blog post that
someone wrote on a whim your and a half
go there is a nougat package called spa
services extensions not just fall
services small services is getting
deprecated spa services extension is
continuing is gonna continue to be
supported there is an entire github
thread on this where people are live it
like most things the way you use it so
we're talking ASP ionic core 3 when you
add that nougat package you get some new
extension methods add spa static files
that's used specifically for production
but it says when I go to production if
you need any small files go to dub dub
dub root and that should because if
you're working with dotnet core that's
where you get your public folders from
controllers and then in configure I just
updated this for done in cor 3 so you
still
set up your end points for NBC or for
web api but you use spa static files for
production and then for development we
turn on use proxy the spa development
server long-winded you tell it the URL
of where your UJS app is running so the
pipeline of any request coming in if
it's just an empty request or a request
to a JavaScript file or CSS it will go
through is this somebody a controller
can handle no well can this ball handle
it let's send it off to UJS and let
bougie-ass handle it the downside of
this process your development server
will never return a 404 it will always
so if you have a request come in for an
API that you're expecting asp.net to
handle and maybe you miss type it you
spell a controller name wrong or
something web api MVC asp.net core is
not going to handle that not going to
return a 404 like you would expect it to
because it's going to send them off to
the spa and it's going to let the spa
handle it and the worst case here is you
get now a 404 you get index.html but
then it's the responsibility of UJS to
realize that is a bad bad URL and give
you a fork or on the client-side I
should have pledged a couple slides in
there because I just thought about that
is a common scenario that screws people
up all right so you run your development
server you go into Visual Studio hit run
and you're running your bjs app on your
asp.net corpore so yay
that's I put that in there because that
is the as a big thing that is not
documented anywhere so if you get these
slides later that will tell you exactly
what you need to do so then in
deployment you first need to compile
your UJS app
using NPM run build this creates a
distribution folder with everything you
need inside of it so you see I have a
couple J s or CSS files as your app gets
bigger this list gets longer and it you
don't need to worry about what's in what
it's all going to be inside a
distribution with index.html well we
want to copy that into our dub-dub-dub
root folder in our dot ASP Emma core app
because when this gets deployed that's
where we're going to pull all of our our
public files from so here we're ignoring
the is development and by just saying
use spa it's going to automatically
point that to dub-dub-dub root for every
request
that's not handled by asp.net core a
little tip here inside of your view
config you can set your output directory
I always set that to my dub-dub-dub root
folder right there so when I do an NPM
run build it automatically goes to the
right place and I don't have to add an
extra step to do the copy now you're
probably doing this in some sort of
continuous integration setup so you
might not have to worry about that but
if you're like me and every now and then
you right click deploy like they tell
you not to this saves you a little bit
of time and I threw this in here just as
a sample slide web pack is kind of a
beast and there's a lot of different
optimizations you can do we use this in
two of our client apps and this worked
really well for optimizing load times
just file sizes and whatnot so if you
want to copy that and play with it I
left in there that is very well
documented on the other hand all right
so how does view talk to asp.net core we
have all this scaffolding set up we know
how to work in development we know how
to do in production yes sir
yes I do actually what I'll do here in a
second I'll show you how I build it
the UJS scaffold will give you a GUID
ignore but it's only good for the UJS
app is not good for the dotnet core app
so what I do is I'm still putting all
these in the same repository I don't
have separate repositories for front-end
back-end I just have app and what I do
is I have a global get ignore that
covers both the view app and the dotnet
core app I'll show you a little trick
that I use the build them alright so you
have everything running you know how to
do development you know how to do
deployments how do you make new Jas
talked asp.net core because I mean you
need data right you put stuff on the
screen you need data to make it actually
work or make it useful this is one of
the points where view is not opinionated
angular is opinionated you use angular's
HTTP provider if you don't we will give
you trouble you doesn't care react
doesn't care either by the way so I'm
not trying to play partial view doesn't
have any built-in mechanism for making
HTTP requests so they say well use your
own it's current generation browsers is
built-in with fetch I prefer a tool
called Axios and this can be used with
not just angular but react or angular to
an extent but it's fetch based it's a
little bit easier to use but it's it's
just Ajax
here's I would suggest fetch fetch is
great cuz it's built in every browser
accepts that guy or believe so y'all
don't have to support that guy so do
whatever you want but this have how
Axios works you import the package you
say I want to make a give request a post
request put to lead whatever to or URL
you can pass in metadata in these
requests but then you just handle the
promise when it returns
so on some sort of success you say yay
success on error you yay or nay the air
so it's just really easy to use but bet
isn't that much different there's others
that are based off of JavaScript a
single wait I don't I think Axios I
think they have a build that supports
async await but I don't know if they
were there yet it's been a while since
I've checked but this is a pretty well
known tool in UJS land this is heavily
used
Axios all right so you get your data now
we need to talk about state management's
and more specifically how do you share
your state between components every
component if I go back to this earlier
slide I should have had it all right let
me do this perfected this slide all the
state for this app and I don't mean I'm
not even declaring any data here is
within the confines of this component if
I want this component to share any state
with its child components it has to
physically pass it in so you see here
this HelloWorld component I'm passing in
a message hello to your VJ s app well
the only way HelloWorld is ever going to
get that information is if I pass it in
now I can declare it as part of my local
state passing in that way and then that
works well what if HelloWorld wants to
pass information back up to this
component you can do that with events so
I can set up events to say well
something happened here's the data you
need to know about but that can get
pretty cumbersome I scroll back down
here
so here's an example I can declare some
data on my component and then I can just
pass that to other components that might
need to know it so a higher-level
component can be the master source of
truth for all state and then pass it
down to other components this is really
good for downstream data so it's easy to
pass data down the stack of components
it is not good for data coming back up
and it's not that it's hard to do it's
just cumbersome you have to write the
events that say well something happens
here's the new data then the other
component says alright here's new data
here's new data all the way back up the
component tree I don't like this
approach you can also take the approach
of each component goes and gets its data
separately but you might run to a
scenario where you're duplicating tasks
you're repeating yourself not
necessarily what you want to do so I
think just following this method for any
large single page applications it's
gonna be difficult to keep state in sync
so this way I don't spend too much time
on it instead I recommend another tool
such as view X some sort of global state
management library and react you have
Redux that's pretty well known you can
also use Redux with you I just not as
many people doing that and view X is
this idea of centralized state
management where any component can ask
for data or update data when it needs to
and everything stays in sync across the
entire application lifecycle so let's
talk about the three fundamental aspects
of UX
yeah UX we have state obviously but then
we have actions and then mutations and
first time I used view X and redux first
time I use redux it took me a couple
times to really understand why I needed
different things to manipulate state I
just was of the opinion can't I just
have state and it works everywhere
no first let's talk about states
specifically state is just an object
that can be made available to any view
components that ask for it and we have
to predefine everything that we want to
store in state not necessarily but if
you want to change tracking you want to
predefined everything so in view X we
tell it this is the default state of my
application and you can put it in
whatever you want to integer strings
objects arrays here's an example
now all these different objects in our
state will be managed if I update global
number it will notify any component in
my app that cares about willable number
that has changed so we get that two-way
sync well how do you update the state
well that's known as a mutation so
you're mutating the state of the app and
this is what necessarily notifies
everything in the app that something's
updated
and there's just simply methods so here
I have two methods one's a success call
something good happened once an error
call well let's say I make that Axios
request to our user API we get back some
user data it's going to call our
mutation that we successfully loaded
user data it'll give us the current
entire state of the app but then it will
also give us the new data that's we just
pulled back now how do I know that's the
the way it goes I should have put in
another slide in here but we'll swing
back here to Axios well that's because I
told it and we'll talk about what commit
is in a moment but I want to call low
user success and I want to pass in the
data from my response or load user error
something bad happens and I want passing
the error of that
heard that's how do we get into our
mutation so the method gets called so
the data passing in is that parameter
that I passed error is the parameter
that I passed state is always given to
me well it's nice about this is because
state represents the entire state of the
app I can change anything in there that
I want to so here I'm just updating the
array I'm replacing the array of users
but in the air I'm setting what was an
empty string - probably a new string but
I'm also changing the global number
imbue X whenever a mutation runs two
things happen first there's a mutation
snapshot it's going to look at the
entire state of your application it's
going to run the mutation it's going to
run another snapshot and it compares the
changes wherever the changes occur users
err load users or global number it's
going to go notify any components that
was that were subscribed to those
changes so the end result is you get
two-way binding it just updates in real
time but how do you call a mutation so
how do we get from the Axios request to
this method call well that's done with
an action and this is where I kind of
thrown off is like why can't I just go
from the Axios call directly to the
mutation with it why do I need to have
his action in between well I don't know
there's there's a the big reason is that
an action can run multiple mutations so
you might have a couple different cases
so here in order to even kick off the
access call I call an action called load
users I'm at a component I tell load
users and you X is going to give me this
context object using objects
what's it called I don't remember what
the term is I'm going to take the commit
method out of it and I want to run my
Ajax request and I'm going to tell you X
I want to commit to the load user
success mutation some data or I want to
commit to the load user's error
mutations some data I can have multiple
commits inside of an action so maybe
there's some different trees I can go
down depending on the current state of
the app I can also inside of my action
call other actions it's not common
that's why I don't have an example of it
but normally your action does one thing
and then serves back a result that
updates the state of the app so this
action goes and does something calls our
mutation that changes the state of the
app and then we go tell all of our
components about it so how do we and our
components map to the state that we care
about because your state object might
have fifty hundred five hundred
properties in it you don't care about
all of them if you're on just the user
view you might just want to subscribe to
two or three of them well there's some
shortcut some helpers built in the view
X two in particular map actions in map
state the map state helper we tell it
well I want to map this users array in
state or the global number object in
state to a property that I call users or
I call some number and these register in
the components as just as just data as
objects I can manipulate so I can render
them on the page so my global number is
some number I can create a list of of
users so for each user inside of users
let's let's write them out because this
is mapped to view X state if anything
changes
sighted users that's going to bubble out
to this component or any component that
subscribes you users and it's going to
update that part of the template same
thing with some number if global number
changes it's going to reflect here and
update the state of this template on the
page so you start getting this two-way
binding that's one side of the equation
the other side is well what if I want to
be the one that initiates the change in
state well that's done with map actions
and inside a map action is used to tell
it what actions do you care about and
this is done with an array we tell it I
want to create a method called load
users and this creates in the local view
context the component context a method
called load users so if I and one of my
methods say alright local load it's
going to go to view X and say I want to
initiate the action load users it kicks
off the axial requests go get some data
data comes back if it's successful it
goes to my mutation my mutation changes
the state the state updates the local
state of the component and the template
updates or if I get the error the error
permeates in the same way all right one
of the other big questions that we get
when when we get down the line is about
authentication this is the this is the
responsibility of asp.net core there's
two methods for authentication most
commonly used
there's the cookie authentication which
if you built a web application in any
time in the past 20 years you know what
cookie authentication is works well for
same same domain systems a SPI core has
had it forever even though it's changed
with every iteration of asp.net cookies
are automatically sent to the server on
any request so if you're making Ajax
requests or
API requests you send the cookie along
with it this is really useful it's easy
to revoke a cookie so if you have a bad
actor say alright we got kicked them out
of the system
you're gonna revoke their cookie the
other way to authenticate is with a JWT
or a JSON web token this is a in the
States we call it the new hotness
which means everyone's using it but
doesn't necessarily mean it's better
it's really useful if you're doing
cross-domain
work so if you have one domain for your
API and other for your client side out
it's easier to pass a token for
authentication than is to try to pass a
cookie
they're also JSON based so if you want
to add metadata to your to your token
maybe what what roles is the user
currently in what's the users email
address you can put that into token and
it's encrypted it's not not hashed but
it's encrypted so the client or anyone
that knows how to decrypt a JWT can read
all that metadata so don't personal
information in those they're also not
sent to the server by default any
requests that you make to a web service
and you want to send a JWT you have to
add it to the request something you
learn the hard way the first time you
start using them and asp net core you
can create JWT s really easily it's
built-in support however there's no
processes for revoking them or
refreshing the tokens a token like a
cookie has a defined expiration date
cookies are a little bit easier to renew
if you if you need to refresh them J div
tees are not you have to write all that
logic yourself unless they have changed
that in asp.net core 3 I don't think
they have because we're using JW tees on
one client app right now and it works it
works really well but we had to write
all of our own refreshing revocation
logic and that's not fun
the other big thing to keep aware of
don't confuse authentication with
authorization I'm naturally hunt so you
go watch him if you want to talk about
this stuff the bigger rule I live by is
don't trust anything on the client that
if the client gives you a request don't
pretend like they know what they're
talking about single page apps you could
potentially have every single view that
the user could possibly see whether they
have permission or not now it's up to
you whether or not you want to provide
data to those views the HTML is just
purely a template it doesn't matter if
my user can see the template for an edit
screen it they don't have permission to
actually edit or get the information for
the screen there's nothing they can do
so we make sure that we do our best on
the client side to make sure that people
can't accidentally see views they're not
allowed to do anything with but on this
server we're especially making sure that
we authorize all over the place or
authorizing by role so if you're not
familiar with asp.net core
authentication and authorization take a
few minutes it's really easy to do and
protect all your different endpoints so
all right in Hindle years this is the
other big one if you are doing the
correct stuff on the server you're
sending back good HTTP responses 404 is
500 500 two's you name it
make sure on your client you're handling
errors and you're telling the person
that an error occurred if they don't
have permission to do something you're
returning a 403 and VCO 403 tell them
you don't have permission to do
something but let the server always be
the single point of truth for anything
that's happening all right I don't have
time to go deep into it but I have a
sample spa that I built for a lot of
these examples on github I also have the
slides up there and that's that's right
on time let me show you the get ignore
stuff I promise I show you
and I will gladly answer any questions
anyone has if they want to want to ask
them get ignored ah I oh I love this
tool you go in here just say what you're
using so I'm using view I'm using PJs
I'm using Visual Studio basically
anything that falls into that category
or vs code create boom copy and paste
that into your get ignore and this will
cover all your bases
what's even nice about it is it gives
you the URL so if you need to make
changes to it in the future you don't
have to re yeah you don't have to figure
out what's changed you can just copy and
paste this into the new get ignore but
this is what we use and they actually
have a command line interface so you
could build this at the command line
alright that's my little Tibbett thank
you all so much for hanging out with me
today let's go party and I hope you
enjoy the rest of NDC
[Applause]